this is the biju this is the bismillah
halal alaikum peace be with you thank
you for tuning in to another episode of
the Dean show do you know that you can
get so much you can be blessed in a way
that's beyond your imagination and make
the best out of your time at the end of
this show you're going to want to throw
away your whole DVD collection if it
consists of stuff esta stallone John
Clooney and all the other Hollywood
superstars and if your music collection
is all about britney spears Lady Gaga
googoo and all that other stuff and you
know what at the end you'll be convinced
if you're sincere you want to know that
all of that is a waste of time and
you're going to be getting rewarded for
spending your time in another manner
when we come back we're going to be
talking about this and giving you some
evidences and trying to connect with the
faculty that God has given you all
around the purpose of life why you've
been created we're going to be talking
about how you can get closer to your
credit through this knowledge with our
next guest here on the Dean show this is
the Jew
does the name Joe this is the things
that angel is an amino
this is the danger this is the danger
please be with you Salaam alaikum peace
be with you at Salaam alaikum how are
you said piece that I'm peace to you are
we people a peace or war people of peace
I mean why is Islam now we know okay
slob submission to the will of God
obeying God worshipping only God same
guy that Jesus worship but now you have
all this hysteria around us love all
this Islamophobia and people painting
Islam like is the other hey it's the big
Hollywood bad guy trying to get you why
you think this is now they see you
because before the knowledge is going to
come and they see you got the you know
beard and the thobe and they think look
at this Arab now al-qaeda and you know
Taliban and all this other stuff and
they're not even there like my turn the
channel they might have bumped in by
accident but you know they're just me
here with these guys going to say we're
going to incriminate them now we got
them they're plotting planning and I'll
blow something up what you gotta say
have you heard this ludicrous seed is
this craziness have you ever heard and
how do you address it we begin the name
of Allah the most merciful alright not
the god of war yeah at the most vengeful
every chapter no plan begins with in the
name of Allah the most merciful a boost
or of mercy say for one chapter all
praise and glory belongs to Almighty God
creator of diamonds in the earth from
the King of Kings master of the universe
and made the peace and blessings of
Allah be upon all his prophets in his
messengers undoubtedly to any genuine
researcher an unbiased reader all these
misconceptions of Islam and being a
bloodthirsty religion and violent and
savage and ruthless and all these
preposterous claims there is nothing but
falsehood but why is it there a loss of
hanukkah tells us a I premise in the
Quran that we must understand where he
said waffle Jael jaco as a half a belted
in albert lea began as a hoopla say to
them o Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him the truth has arrived and
falsehood has perished falsehood is
bound to perish person can think of it's
bound to Paris then why was it there it
only left when truth came when truth and
falsehood right authentic knowledge and
fake knowledge are sitting on the same
table there's no comparison but when
there is incorrect information out there
about Islam then anything could be
inflated with hot air and you assume
that it's worthwhile so basically the
ignorance is one thing and another
because as you said Islam is the fast
growing religion in the world in fast
growing religion United States and the
fastest growing religion amongst women
cambridge university is unreal
statistics about how fast is lamb
Cambridge University absolutely about
how is fastest lamb will grow in the
next few years and a lot of people out
there that don't like this people that
don't care what the truth is they just
want to keep making their dollars and
they want to live what they think is the
high life at the expense of humanity
right so they're going to distort the
image of Islam because the only
legitimate competition that has you know
survive the test of time and survived
the test of criticism and is spreading
like a gentle wildfire throughout the
earth amazing Amanda we got some
statistics here that we show in the
polls by FBI that they did this research
and it's amazing they try to spread this
false fallacy about Islam like spreading
terror and havoc but if you look at the
statistics of where Islam is on the
totem pole here it has the lowest
percentage of terrorist acts because you
got crackpots and every religion isn't
that true if you Bethlehem research
their religion with for short absolutely
why is our news media foaming at the
mouth when it comes to stories about
Islamic terrorists but not white guy
terrorists is that because Muslims are a
bigger threat in fact between 1980 and
2005 ninety-four percent of all the
attempted or successful terrorist
attacks on US soil were not carried out
by Islamic radicals but instead by
non-muslims mostly white guys so then
why the obsession we say peace we mean
peace and we want peace but peace comes
from the crater that observed so we
first got to submit to the owner of
peace and you can't do that without what
we're going to be targeted knowledge you
can't talk about God without knowledge
you know you want to talk about you know
I start talking about the President and
I don't know his biography and you know
you're going to start upsetting people
what about the crater so isn't that one
of the most important things now is to
seek knowledge to get a GED master's
degree PhD but what's the virtue
seeking knowledge of the purpose of life
why you've been created a lot of the
Most High says no quran in one verse
your file a Latina a minus Minko one
Latino to the el modelo jet Allah raises
those that have been given faith amongst
you and those who have been given
knowledge many degrees the famous stuff
seer scholar the portal bo Harold law
says what this means that Allah raises
every person with faith above everyone
doesn't have faith he gets with that an
elevation then he raised the people of
knowledge on top of the believers so if
a believer gets paradise eternally and
the good life in this world then what
does a person get that has knowledge on
top of his faith and he has excelled in
that aspect Allah has even honored
forgive me for the example a dog in the
Quran because of him being educated in
the verbatim word of God the Quran God
Almighty's honoring a dog in some of the
Maya and the fifth chapter of the Quran
Allah says with regards to the animals
that are allowed to eat he includes in
them one man I'll em to me Nell Joey
Hugh Calladine to Ali muna him to ali mu
na hoona me my lemon law which means and
also is permissible for you to eat the
dogs catch a hunting dog that you taught
from what Allah taught you these are the
verses if he brings back a catch for you
and you know he's the one that caught it
you're allowed to eat that even though
normally dead meat and it has such the
dog but this is an honor for the dog
because of some knowledge so what will
knowledge due to a dignified upright
human being right who is placed on this
earth to lead the planet in goodness and
in charity and in progress and in
development and in civilization this
exact word is landed in the days when
they valued knowledge just you mentioned
dogs do muslims hate dogs you've heard
this absolutely the ruling on a dog
saliva in islam is that it's impure
right it's alive / dep so lutely and
there's scientific research to back this
up and there are human elements that are
impure as well when a person goes to the
bathroom the things the matters that he
releases the substances are we don't
hate human beings right so perhaps this
is one of the cheap shots that people
take hoping that others will not go back
and research
but that happened early level praise
belongs to Allah the likes of these week
assaults actually lead people to go back
and learn about Islam and increases the
numbers so when your research this you
go ahead and use the faculties of the
crazies given you you don't just blindly
follow ignorant people you research you
see that this is you know a lot of these
things you know are false and fallacies
they're not facts and how can you be
someone who's you've submitted to God
you're Muslim Jesus was a Muslim Abraham
was a Muslim Moses was a Muslim last and
final messenger all of the prophets of
god were those who submitted to not
Jesus they didn't worship a holy goes
Trinity and stick in a stone and a bone
they worship the one who created
everything and where his creatures so we
want to worship the one who created us
that's what Islam is all about if you
could dig that you dig Islam so tell us
now you're a Muslim but you don't have
knowledge now you're flaring up and you
hear these degra gating things about
Islam your religion and this can usually
causes people to go and do a rational
thing we're not people emotional people
burning flag jumping out cars creating
havoc riots if you are studying your
religion you can intellectually combat
lot of these silly arguments this is
true absolutely even many of the people
that misunderstand the concept of jihad
for example right that jihad means go
out there and set the throats the Koran
used the word jihad right in a context
in Mecca in the early years of Islam
before battle self-defense battle was
even permitted when Allah said to the
prophet muhammad sallallahu ala allah
peace and blessings be upon him while
Jay hit home be he jihad and kuvira and
makes you had against them with it it is
what the quran meaning intellectually
bring to them the arguments bring to
them the proof because the arguments
made by the creator of the heavens and
the earth and the creator of the human
mind cannot be stood in front of right
so this is of the ways that people
dispel the misconceptions and make clear
the wise so that the people can see as
clear as day this is Islam and this is
what works for me and this is what my
happiness and my salvation is contingent
upon that's based on knowledge you got
down you got to open the books you got
to read watch visual if you don't like
to read watch get off of all the reality
shows and all that other nonsense mtv
cribs and pick my ride and you're
wasting time we'll be right back with
more here on the detail whatever allah
commands me to do you need to do this
land has tolerance and mercy and
compassion to know that allah you know
will forgive you as long as you do what
you need to do as long as you turn back
to him it's learn the system of mercy
and compassion and it is for the best
benefit of all of the people that
surround it muslim muslim
motion
who
who
Oh
Oh
it's a way of life brought to us bad the
messenger best of me show us the way to
unless chris this is the Dean Dean
Addison this is the Dean do you nervous
back here on the Dean show and we are
with Mohammed as Chanel we thank you for
finding the time to be with us a cycle
of hidden it's my pleasure and we're
talking about the importance of
knowledge to people see the benefits of
getting a master's degree GED you know
completing something in a trade and
we're not called to be monks you know
when when the young man or young woman
they start getting you know closer to
the purpose of life they research here
based on evidence that this provide that
the crater provides for us it's clear
now that people starting old your shift
now you know they start they get you a
shake now you grow a little bit of birth
the woman's getting more modest and and
now they start to put this down they
start why do you think this is the
friends there are you also Muslims all
this guy's turn into a shake now he's
praying ollie and they start to belittle
the Dean why do you think it says hola
hey this is a complicated subject that
has deep roots and and and old fountains
that I sprouts from but in a nutshell
will say this goes back to the heart as
we assume people of the Sunnah follow
the prophet sallallaho selling the
original Orthodox organic understanding
of Islam we hold that faith begins in
the heart and it is in the heart and
it's part of action inseparable right so
the heart is healthy and able to benefit
you on the day of judgment so losses an
opera and nothing will benefit on that
day no wealth no children except someone
that comes to allow the healthy heart
the skulls that a healthy heart can only
come when it has been freed from two
elements
the first of them is Shuba has meaning
doubts and misconceptions and the second
is Jehovah temptations right so the
issue of doubts and misconceptions this
can only be repelled to save your heart
with authentic knowledge if a person
doesn't know this is a part of the Dean
he may fall into the trap of what making
fun criticizing lampooning someone for
doing Dean all right applying Islam and
he has no idea this system is a disaster
right there's an even greater disaster
many times nowadays we see people may
get into college and they see philosophy
professors and just the art of rhetoric
even though I have my reservations about
that just complexity for the sake of
sounding cool sounding sophisticated
people come in to college and they say
all religions are man-made huh and they
prove it they say and they strike
examples with a certain religion the
most prominent religion in the country
for example I Christianity and this has
been almost accepted hands down now 2006
new york times magazine on the cover
page was called the end of christian
america how everyone's just leaving
Chris chances on the new york times
magazine to 2006 so he proves with
christianity that it's been man-made and
I his seat didn't I tell you all
religions are man-made and then when the
Muslim doesn't know his religion he
thinks his religion doesn't have answers
with other religion doesn't have answers
so he puts his head down as well this is
a disaster this is a doubt that entered
his heart and could lead to disbelief
and meeting Allah denying his existence
or denying his authority over the
creation or denying his right to be
worshipped and this was the message of
all the prophets worship God alone
without any partners the second
temptation the second disease of the
heart is temptations and the only way to
repel temptations we said douses with
knowledge temptations is with the fear
of Allah and you will not fear Allah no
I love him nor trust him nor hope in him
none of these until you know him so in
reality they both go back to knowledge
allah subhana Allah The Exalted in the
highest is in the Quran in my official
ahem in a bad hit when I map it is only
those slaves of Allah that have
knowledge that truly fear him that truly
fear him so this sanctity of your heart
if you care about it the Gateway is
knowledge and that's why
it's no surprise at the very first word
to come down from that piranhas what if
Cora recite in the name of your Lord so
now you have for instance on one and you
have reality shows daytime drama night
and drama sports video games and then
you have time that can be spent learning
the verbatim word of God the Quran
watching a lecture where a person of
knowledge is explaining the Quran he's
talking about a certain topic that
relates to the current society helping
to you increase in Salaam where is there
more benefit where are you going to get
more reward the comparison between to
those tools like the comparison of this
world in the next because all of those
first category ended the grave and the
second category has benefits without end
without end and many people say no but
it's okay I already have that the
benefit of that and I know my Dean and a
person needs to be honest with himself
don't lie to yourself and don't trick
yourself because you're not gonna trick
a lot of load of the world's right I met
a brother in college during the daytime
from a blunt drinking coffee I was like
are you okay are you sick reason why
you're not fasting he said yall may you
don't know what happened what happened
he said i forgot to make sure hope I
forgot to take the short a meal before
dawn that you know I confess I said so
what he said so I can't fast said who in
the world told you that who told you
that if you don't eat that snack you're
not allowed to fast it's on the
condition of the fast and he broke his
fast breaking the fast in the daytime in
Ramadan is is a major major sin is one
of the pillars of Islam right you can
say but he's excused he didn't know he
might be but in reality you're only
excused by ignorance for the things that
you had no access to knowing you know
another example on the day of very the
father came to me and said to me you
know is it true that a person that's
very embarrassing a person when he gets
married in Ramadan he has three days
succour do you mean three days as you
know
so Allah you has three days you know
like a grace period leeway and I was
like no who told you I said a share and
this is the concept of course the
concept of share and wanted to share and
where does knowledge come come from we
need to revisit the sources of our Dean
and revisit the quran and sunnah and and
the lives of the early muslims how they
understood it a line that is clarity and
in that is happiness and in that is the
fear of Allah and that is loving your
religion and being proud of your
religion all through knowledge how could
we get people motivated more because
sometimes it's very difficult to sit
okay you're just programmed in your
condition and it's even sometimes you
know action-packed thriller and you're
flipping through that you can't sit
still nowadays everything is just moving
so fast fast food fast cars fast
everything's fast fast Dean right I'm
not feeling it you know what I mean
maybe you know I don't I'm turning the
lecture and I'm it's difficult sometimes
for some people but I think if people
see that for every second is it true if
I'm lying cut me off for every second
that you're sitting benefiting by
learning the Dean obviously it's going
to benefit you can help you develop to
be the best human being get you closer
to Allah to Jenna you're getting
rewarded for every second but over here
watching all that garbage you can you're
getting sins so how pound on this
benefit your is it true every second
you're watching a let's say they're
watching us right now is a rewarding it
absolutely to the degree that many of
the scholars held the view that after
the obligations after fulfilling your
duties your respective duties the
greatest act you can do in Islam bar
none is to seek knowledge sitting there
listening seeking out else you're going
to seek knowledge you're listening or
you're reading right uh lee muhammad
rahimullah used to say seeking knowledge
is not equated buy anything if your
intention is correct you just want to
get closer to allah learn more about his
deen learn how to please him and obey
Him and the likes and i'm malik rahim
allah medica that's one of the four
Great Imams again his student I believe
it was a blow but no Ibrahim Allah uh he
got up after one of the prayers and the
class remember it was about to begin and
he started praying soon started pranks
on
so I told him sit down before he started
he said for that which you got up for is
not better than that which you're
sitting for prayer is the second pillar
of Islam the greatest action in islam
after you make a testimony of faith
that's how you become Muslim many of the
scouts held the view that seeking
knowledge is greater than even the
voluntary prayers so there's no there is
no time lost with seeking knowledge
picking up a book watching a lecture and
audio in the car instead of music
contaminating your brain this is
empowering you no time lost only good
deeds rather the right intention I'm is
gained and not just good deeds bad deeds
are lost time is gained how when you
learn knowledge you're able teach it to
someone that means if you show up on the
day of judgment and you haven't you know
got 10 out of 10 on every subject you've
lived another lifetime you taught
someone how to do something you get all
of that in your scale as well so perhaps
a person has gained time that he lived
life times through others by teaching
them what he learned and also he said
not just good deeds you lose your bad
deeds the Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him said that even the
the the ant and the fish in the sea seek
forgiveness for the seeker of knowledge
sepang and he said salallahu r is
another authentically that know people
get together to seek knowledge and
remember allah accept that they are told
stand for you have been forgiven so it's
really something to think about when
you're playing all the xbox games
wasting time Grand Theft Auto and all
the other nonsense is out there you're
wasting time losing time getting bad
deeds instead of good deeds would right
back with more here in a Dijon okay
you've got your dream home and you've
got your dream car but you're going to
get old and things are going to happen
to you in your life and then what have
you got at the end of the day is an
empty dream that has no real foundation
we are going to dine and we're going to
meet our Lord and he is going to judge
us it becomes an obligation for each
single human being to find out what the
Quran is Islam is telling us to stay
away from things which are bad for your
person embed for the society
this is the biju this is the danger back
here on the Dean show and time is short
so we got a few more points we want to
cover I think this is so amazing that
you know and I really because a lot of
people are caught up into wasting time
with you know the xbox and you know the
reality show is this something very
important to cut this out I heard one
person of knowledge saying that
shakedown is not howdy 49 he comes in to
the person's house and he sees the TV's
not the TV it said but what comes on the
cable TV no and he leaves that my job is
done here hi so is this something
tangible that people can do just cut off
this cable we're ninety-five percent of
the stub promiscuous even many of the
commercial showing naked women and
people kissing and all this stuff that
contaminates the heart and put on some
good programming that's going to help
you to increase in goodness having to
rely on is part of being a Muslim is
loving Allah and His Messenger and the
Muslims you know if you can allow me
even the Muslim Justice Initiative
brothers that I try to collaborate with
in New York Muslims for justice org
these are people concerned the night and
day and they don't find the time they're
the only people work and they can't find
people to back them and they wish that
the brothers and sis would visit their
website and I like Muslim brothers and
sisters that are telling you number one
we have been helping our Muslim brothers
and sisters just in our locality just in
the united states that have been
prosecuted for nothing that have been
framed or otherwise that have received
unjust treatment or haven't been given a
fair trial love for your brother would
you love for yourself even if what
you're watching is not impermissible and
unlawful or up for scholarly debates you
know even one of those brothers that was
given a 30-year sentence or where the
thought of him Hannah male of work on
impatience and all the brothers and
sisters out there that I've been locked
up wrongfully he says my message to the
Muslims outside is to not take blessings
for granted he said you know like what
he said like a doorknob said huh he said
you can get up and turn that doorknob
and walk out right
I can't I was just something profound
you know something really and it really
had is the heart you know then you can
get up and walk out go give your mother
kiss on the cheek you know read a book
attend the lecture give something out
about Islam people dying to find out
about Islam Allah knows you may plant
the seed that you can never imagine what
a little sprout look at the brothers
from these two siblings from the NFL all
right free ages they put their career on
hold for Islam I'm asking you to do
something for the deen of allah soprano
dada right gaining nearness you say I
know my Dean a lot of the Most High says
Paul Hellyer Stella denied a moon I'm a
lady in ala ala moon tell them o
muhammad sallallaahu are they were
seldom can they ever equate those that
have knowledge those that don't forget
the scholars and the layman know even
yourself when you gain knowledge about
the Dean not just facts not just
superficial stuff when you're close and
connected I mean ok the bag wedding is
impermissible that has a certain effect
as opposed to knowing that the prophet
muhammad sallallahu audio seldom
ascended through the heavens in the
night journey and he saw people with
brass nail breast nails and they were
clawing themselves and their cheeks and
their faces and the light who are these
these the people that used to scrape
away and eat at the honor of others mean
they use the back right and speak about
slander people look at the difference we
know a superficial fact and knowing
detailed knowing a muslim goes to
paradise forever and then you read about
the descriptions of paradise and the
likes that allah comes to the people of
paradise and he tells them do you want
anything more they say how can we ever
want anything more when you've given us
what you never gave anyone he says I'll
give you that I make permanent for you
my pleasure amazing yeah that feeling
something you can never get in the soil
that's due now no matter how pious you
are you still worried that yeah it
hasn't been accepted you still worried
that you may fall off before you die or
the likes but when you come into contact
with the Quran and Sunnah this nurtures
your heart you become a different human
being they can't equate so make yourself
a different human being that's what I
would leave with we're going to just
start close up something tangible some
more something tangible okay now they're
looking at their DVD collection got
Sylvester Stallone Brad Pitt you know J
Lo and you are like a hundred DVDs here
and you got fifty cents and Kid Rock and
all the cds
you know but the the the empowerment
through what the crater wants us to do
in Quran and hadith this is empty so
what can you do right now what I do it
all this stuff Elijah of the greatest
blessings and tests test of time right
where it not so great lo not have swore
by it when he said well asked I swear by
the passage of time and as they say a
person's days or three the day that
passed it's already gone and the day
that's coming is not guaranteed and all
that remains is today and today all you
have today is your moment you don't know
the next moment is going to come right
so live the moment the greatest of
athletes the greatest professionals they
say I can't waste a moment you know so i
ask allah ta'ala to make these words
sincere and make them benefit a lot of
care for our Muslim brothers and sisters
and for the non-muslims out there do not
belittle anything and as they say
procrastination is the grave in which
you bury opportunity don't meet a lot
listening to a CD or cursing someone out
or caring or something that is not worth
caring about rather be be transformed
through the knowledge that Allah
revealed into a different type of human
being and this will transfer you be
better to your parents will be more
productive in society doing good as a
site doing good to your neighbor doing
good to your family to your friends
you'll be a better human being if you
get this knowledge is that true
absolutely because these are the signs
that all loves a person that he believes
and does all these good deeds and so I
had no clarity he said peace and
blessings be upon him that's when Allah
wishes well for a person he loves a
person he gives him understanding in the
Dean so they go hand in hand inseparable
thank you very much for the hardest
times that was thank you may God
Almighty Creator rewards you and above
these things is like a look later oh
yeah and thank you for tuning in to
another episode of the Dean show now you
be the judge now you're going to have to
go back if you're doing being doing good
things inshallah God willing where
courage to do more good things spend
time getting to know this way of life so
you can be confident knowing that you're
living the correct way of life the way
of life that's based on proof on
evidences and it's from the creator of
the heavens and earth and you're proud
to be one who has submitted to the One
God not worshipping his creation but
worshiping the Creator knowing your
purpose in life knowing that in store if
you keep living this beautiful good life
this organic way of living wholesome way
that produces nothing but good you got
paradise at the end and you're not
wasting time
and that's what we wanted to persuade
you to be away from wasting time doing
things that have no benefit so at the
end now it's your choice what do you
want you want paradise something that's
eternal or you keep following your lusts
and desires and you end up in a hot
place because their judgment is
something that's going to be it's ahead
of all of us and we want to be
successful on that day so it's up to you
and if you like what we had to say
continue to tune it or give us a call
operators are standing by you want to
gain peace call us at one eight hundred
662 Islam we're here every day to answer
your questions at this number you can
also pick up the new dunya to Dean at
this website tune in every week for a
new show we'll see you next time God
willing peace be with you
this is the danger this is the danger